Tor alert baby look out stay trashy tour
is about to kick in the full swing gang
we're adding cities we're adding shows
tickets are going quick come out and see
us Little Live stand up comedy plus we
pay ayg with the crowd it's a good good
time come and hang with the boys yeah
baby in March we're knocking out
Baltimore Virginia Beach Richmond
Virginia Oklahoma City Dallas Texas
Houston Texas Austin Texas second show
added New Haven Connecticut there's
about two tree tickets left if they're
even available anymore we got Burlington
Vermont Tampa second show out of first
so showed out Dania Beach Florida
Raleigh North Carolina Louisville
Kentucky just added Cleveland and
Columbus get those tickets more cities
coming soon let's party let's do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's a little
shall we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find that the group to
be classy yeah just a big old piece of
trash trash I'm your hosting fully
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at antuti's basement she's
upstairs down to sleep yet I don't know
how she sleeps through all that goddamn
construction going on up there what is
she doing out back I don't know there
was a pool guy here there was a hot tub
guy here I don't know that was just last
night I think she was knocking boots
I thought I heard the Jackhammer going
in the middle of the night that was Tony
she's doing something up there I don't
know what the [__] going man have you
heard anything about what the settlement
was what did she's real real
tight-lipped about it she's been very
tight-lipped about it uh I can tell you
whatever she's doing she didn't pull
permits and it ain't enough to go man
that thing looks he's shoddy
craftsmanship up there the city is going
crazy
trying to figure out Ellen is Gonna Come
and shut her down might have the Eagles
playing there next year who knows Mike
Carlos is coming at you from across the
table he is the CEO of Ru garbage he is
an international businessman has Us in
financial ruin ladies yeah what are you
talking about this is Tony's fault give
it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan everybody
what's up gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate if you
subscribe on iTunes whole video
available on YouTube and as you know
those numbers are
cooking and then obviously the greatest
gosh darn website of all time shout out
to Al Gore for inventing the internet it
is
www.patreon.com are you garbage you sign
up over there you get episodes uh bonus
episodes ayg you get episodes of hard
feeling which is I gotta be honest with
you the [__] money maker
couple of whales hey you're a real radio
in this
extra shot in the coffee this morning
kid huh this kid's on drugs don't forget
Jingle Bell concert
get your tickets now
if you have a Jack Frost Big Boulder
shout out to it uh yeah check it out
that's a lot of fun over there a lot of
we're doing a lot of [__] yeah we're
having a good time over on the patreon
gang come on board have fun with us and
have a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good works till ones
works the twos crosses the t's tops the
eyes and he's got that big old wee-wee
T-Bone mcgruffins Toby McMullen
everybody what's up dudes what up
literally forgot your name for a second
there not gonna lie ah one of my closest
friends
work hard your dreams come true Jack
Frost Big Boulder yeah that's a
throwback sure because I couldn't that
was that that might as well have been
Mars to me that might as well have been
Aspen dude so Jack for the for the
non-uh regional guy uh and gal Jack
Frost Big Boulder is the Philadelphia
Poconos it's like the dirtbags Chateau
you know what I mean
go up you get a hot tub and you make bad
decisions
snow machines they use up there they use
snow machines everywhere though dude
except like the [__] you know the the
real good spots but yeah they have to
make snow yeah there's no way it snows
like four feet a nice ski trip would be
awesome for the boys that'd be a fun
little Retreat yeah I know I got hurt
when I'm back I'm a lodge man from here
on out what do you mean nice hot toddy
yeah making a run and some damage at the
corner of the bumper hopefully it's my
wife dude falling in fake snow was like
catching a bleach snow cone dude it's
just so gross in your mouth yeah it's
not great is it that what it is I
thought it was just water and air I
don't know what it is it's chemically
yeah well it has to be has to be able to
freeze above freezing temperatures oh
[__] I thought that it can only make
snow when it's freezing it has to be
cold enough to make they can't just make
it in it's not snow you would see in L.A
you were doing meth dude
they take a hose and like spray it real
thin so it instantly freezes watch
instant mashed potatoes
I'm skiing like a dirtbag over there
eating cotton balls uh I saw you pull a
move
um right before we recorded I understand
you were jammed up Toby
um but it got me thinking because I
think you might do this oh boy the
deodorant it gets applied before you put
your shirt on right
okay that is that's weird man we've
we've talked about this a little bit I
think I don't know that's man you don't
you're not you did that because you were
you forgot to put deodorant on I didn't
have the I ran out of the stuff that I
like at the crib and I have to keep an
extra set in here just in case but you
would normally put it on before you put
your shirt on absolutely not after shirt
post shirt
what
what because it gets on your shirt and
that happens to you and you don't see it
you have deodorant stains on your shirt
a lot we might have talked about it I
feel so crazy I get that it's crazy but
you look even trashy you're walking
around with white stains all over your
[__] shirt like a goober can't land
any broads like that [__] got Right
Guard all over your sides nah it's tough
yeah no no no no it started out a
necessity of not having clothes to then
change into because in the morning
you're in a rush you're getting dressed
you put your deodorant on and you get
all jammed up on the sides
I don't think so I know so I mean dude
the last time we had this conversation
you literally had deodorant stains on
the side of your shirt that's impossible
because I didn't start using white
deodorant until it doesn't matter the
the oil still it gets wet see you can
see it on your shirt I use the blue
stuff the Old Spice blue
yeah yeah I get alcohol burns from that
yeah it's like a goddamn chemical fire
in there
it's like Fight Club yeah sometimes you
catch a thin batch of that stuff it's
light only deodorant heavy on the
Alcohol I've scratched myself with these
couples screaming me yikes I'm trying to
sit here and [__] do his show I got
screaming piss feels like you got a shot
I hate that burning no I'm strictly uh
Dove or Victoria's Secret baby powder
baby Victoria's Secret no not Victoria's
Secret
what's the broad deodorant secret yeah
give me a little secret
hey guys hey this is chicken sandwich
Just Between Us Jimmy's got a butt plug
in
strap it on a b cup we're all looking at
your wife Babel smell like [__] if I
don't
ask me my G string
a couple of tampons with me
man I've been calling that stuff
Victoria's Secret for quite some time
just secret I've been asking him the
pharmacy yeah laughs
hey you guys gotta you got a back
section with a beaded door I can go
shopping
good stuff yeah no I go after it's it's
strictly preventative it's not ideal but
I I've ruined too many mornings leaving
the house and I have [__] I have I
have deodorants now that you mentioned I
think we have discussed this and yeah I
just I I thought about it this morning
because I remember seeing you do that a
lot uh-huh surprised I'm surprised that
you Toby I think officially
and put it out there I think most people
would put it on before I understand that
is the process yeah I it's it's more of
I just I think Birds might do it uh
after for that reason you're talking
yeah it just it just gets on my shirts
it's just more of a prevention I
wouldn't call it garbage chicks
sometimes really coat that on I'll do
you I I get it heavy you do I run
through [__] deodorant sticks man
that's the one thing I had I wasn't
there was what I never liked gambling
too much I never got any acne I didn't
really have a lot of hair and I never
really had bo
yeah I don't have it's not a problem
it's just more of like a while I'm there
I'm like let's get a good base on here
you know what I mean like if I'm doing
the job let's do it so you know
sometimes we're out late if we leave at
[__] 9 A.M We're Not Gonna I'm not
gonna get home tonight until [__]
goddamn 10 o'clock that's a 14-hour day
or someone dude
man that's a long day you got to be able
to you know the clock's ticking I gotta
stay fresh I hear you what if I end up
at a happy hour or something or a
[__] you know a nightcap somewhere
I'm gonna be fresh somebody set you up
straight from the office to happy hour
ladies Gang This is a family episode
and apparently the emergency brake works
caught a fire department will you oh
cool this down a little bit uh I got so
I got a little something I wanted to
talk to you it's trashy to me and I
won't do it it's causing a big riff in
the family yeah at the moment in the
family my wife okay Hans he's on the
fence about it I'm still waiting to hear
back
uh she's been going and looking
at okay houses to buy uh-huh not to buy
just to go yeah uh that we like proper
cannot afford she goes herself yeah I
like that so what do you think we spend
all of your money
it's just a patreon
uh
uh it's a it's a thing of like I'd be so
embarrassed if they were like oh are you
thinking about making I couldn't lie I
assumed that you couldn't just when when
I was a kid is because we used to do
that [__] we used to do that as a family
and me and my houses me and my boys
would do that too I mean there's no way
the realtor thought you and your boys
were no no we would we wouldn't go in
but me and my boys in high school would
smoke up we'd hop in the station wagon
my buddy Charlie's mom's white station
wagon called it the Millennium Falcon
and we'd roll around Lady Killers huh
[Laughter]
it looks like you're throwing it into
Hyper Speed yeah I have my super Circle
Super Soaker on me oh man we're all
thumbs today
um but we'd roll around on a Saturday
and just go look at the nice
neighborhoods around sure that's one
thing you're [__] high that's
different this is a you're you're high
driving around with nowhere to go you
can't go back to your house you can
[__] you'll get clipped you know what
I mean but I do remember my parents as a
kid we would just like on a Saturday
let's go see what's out there that we
can't afford yeah that's crazy and go
and go in and walk around but I assume I
have too much I would feel like they
would start asking questions and I would
lie I don't think I could I thought they
did a credit check that's what I still
think like can we just go like say we
were out in L.A all right we're out in
L.A doing something uh-huh could we just
go and look at it open she's setting
appointments
okay she's not this isn't an open house
where they're like hey anybody come if
you live in the neighborhood from one to
four
she has this woman driving around to see
a park driving her around she's on the
upper west side just wasting people's
time
ladies got kids to feed I know dude she
showed her everything from apartments
that were like two hundred thousand
dollars to performance they're like 2.7
that's like something else like there's
no way she thinks you're buying who
looks at a [__] studio apartment than
a four bedroom High Rock what are we
doing here I'm like this bro it's all
over just look at a commercial space
I got a supermarket down in the village
Ah that's [__] up that's like
something that the lady didn't fight
club just pretending to [__] be
whatever going around no she uh no so
the woman knows nothing on that Toby
thanks Toby's real funny [__] over and
saw your dead eyes Jesus Christ
yo this car's not even laughing at my
flubs
you didn't laugh at that joke I said
improperly piece of [__]
um wow that's uh no but the woman is the
woman's also kind of taking the lead I I
can't throw the whole thing on she was
like oh we also have these and these and
these and these and I was like yeah sure
I'll take a look she's getting in the
car yeah she said it was a rough car too
sure it wasn't like he didn't like stop
wasting this ladies no she was like I
can also show you the like she's
desperate she probably has no friends
she should have qualified the lead I
might [__] driving you're driving
around somebody you can't buy but so
you're telling me that if there's an
open house in like the Hollywood Hills
we could just go yeah I think people in
La do that maybe it's been in movies
like they go just for like they put out
like food and stuff really yeah like I
think a lot of like you know Bad Comics
or actors like walk around like they
play like a different character you know
what I mean like oh yeah what just for
like fun like shits and giggles oh they
go in like their [__] Theodore
[__] uh van nostring yes I could
catch one of those girls from uh selling
Sunset you ever see that show
no I just want to take a dump in a
really nice bathroom I'm just gonna take
a shower
I hit the song like a little leg room
you know got some people coming over in
about a half an hour you're in the pool
I gotta test it again
jumping off the roof and [__] yeah
um but I guess the big man said this is
a gosh Dorn Family episode to re-enter
it is when you sign up for patreon uh
you get to answer your we'll get you'll
get to ask your garbage question we'll
answer it on the air just the best way
to doing a lot of submissions the ig's
the emails but patreon gets first crack
at it just a squad just the boys
um uh let's see this one's from Bucky
five six five twenty dollar homie since
hachimachi Hey Big Spender talk about
getting on the ground floor I haven't
had one red is it garbage to own
anything cheetah print
cheetah print is a garbage Zone anything
cheated I think you would be
hard-pressed to find anything classy
that is cheating for a minute though
that was cool right weren't the birds
wearing leopard stuff I think like kind
of ironically a little bit like you know
what I mean I don't think you'd show up
to like a wedding in a leper and a
cheetah dress like I think like you're
going out if you had like are you sure
about that I think so I don't I thought
that was popular I mean if you saw a
girl roll into a wedding in a cheetah
print everybody would think she's a
hooker or Shania Twain yeah I I miss
Twain is the only one that can pull it
off either way I'm thinking of Swing
that's all that tells me I can tell you
what the trashiest cheetah print thing
is what the seat belt pad oh that's
tough that's what I'm saying instead
[__]
hookies hug boats uh what are you making
moves on Uber drivers
I think uh yeah that's what I'm saying
it's always like
it's you know [__] type clothing that
you would see in a traditionally like in
movies or whatever how about accessories
like a handbag or whatever a handbag
sure if done I mean is there like coach
leopard print otherwise I think would be
trashy is that what you is that what
you're graded on Coach huh I don't mean
I don't know anything look at you that's
my favorite TV show in the 90s
did you get money for that
talk about diversifying this guy's got
his own handbag line
shout out to Craig T huh breaking in the
keys um I don't uh yeah I don't know
what else is leopard print it would be
classy
it would have to be something that you
could wear I mean dude if we were going
out to dinner and you're if me and my
wife and you and your girl you showed up
in like a spandex [__] cheetah but
you'd be like what are you doing get you
know Peggy Bundy yeah exactly that's
what I'm saying
it's never anybody fast no
sure it's always one of those things I
think it's one of those things that
trashy people think is classy hmm you
know what I mean all right that's that's
where I would fall on it I don't think
there's any acceptable animal prints
except maybe snakeskin boots I'll give
you that you got to be like an oil
tycoon too I don't have a Cadillac to go
with us yeah zebra's pretty sweet
I guess certain way like a raw I don't
know didn't listen somebody to show up
wearing a lion head somewhere
one of one of those celebrities that was
The Lion King uh
uh one of the Kardashian ladies he had
like a huge lion head I don't think you
can do that might have been at the Met
Gala or whatever that thing is where all
those rich people dressed they'd be
shunned we're in an actual lionhead
right I don't think you can wear I don't
think popular culture in Hollywood could
wear that would be a PR nightmare Furs
out right I think so yeah okay
I would have fair enough it's trashy
um all right let's see here I don't this
is from Andrew uh ten dollar first time
long time ten dollar homie here I don't
know
I think we've met we've mentioned it but
I don't know if we have a rolling is
cutting the top of the chip bag so it's
easier to eat the big bags deeper trashy
or not
cutting like you get halfway down a bag
of Ruffles a big bag of Ruffles you cut
it
I think that is classy then you have a
you have a clip you have a clip I think
you would clip either way I'll say I'm a
real tight roll my only thing with
Trader Joe's is they don't have the
resealable sometime on their things
because they make these uh chickpea and
like pea like rings they're like Funyuns
they're so good but there's no
resealable once you get in once it's
open yeah it's game over you got to put
it away yeah but I don't know I don't I
think to me that's trashy
that's like taking the
I don't know for some reason it doesn't
you're damaging the your damage in the
product yeah
it just seems It's like toothpaste well
obviously the classiest thing you could
do is put it in a bowl
what what chips for who then then you
got to eat the whole thing yeah no this
is to store it back I'll tell you what
is trash if you open up a bag of Doritos
a regular bag of Doritos finding those
in the Ziploc bag in the in the pantry
somebody's house no thank you oh no that
and cereal and the Tupperware I think my
sister does that yikes hey this is what
the [__] I need to know how long these
kicks been in here yeah no that shit's
[__] whack yeah I'm not I don't eat I
don't eat breakfast at her place unless
it's a couple of screamed this ain't no
sitcom honey that's put that [__] away
that I never that just seems like work
more work than anything
yeah now I don't uh
I want everything in the bag or box that
it was designed to come in right that's
how I feel otherwise I feel it's like
somebody's been rubbing their Ruby
fingers through it I need something
fresh untouched you know what I mean
because you know they definitely drugged
their hand to get it in the bag or the
box but a bag of chips you slice it you
put you you fold it once put the clip on
that's all right I don't know okay let's
talk about that Adam and Eve
let's talk about getting weird knock
knock who's there my boner let's go
right this way to my butthole ladies and
gentlemen gang do yourself a favor spice
things up yeah have a good time have a
good time with yourself save a little
cash on dinner in the movies meeting her
girlfriends when you can get a little
dildo and go home and stick it right up
your butthole right what are we doing
here let's go this is a goddamn family
program big Feller uh if you go to Adam
how do you think those kids got there
Adam and Eve picking things off little
appetizer go to adamandeve.com right now
Adam and Eve is offering our listeners
50 off just about any item plus free
shipping and Rush processing because if
you're hard you gotta get it quick
keep waiting six to eight weeks for
delivery I got a hard on now it's my
boner and I gotta come let's go uh no
matter how much you spend or what you
buy everything will be packaged and sent
discreetly thank you very much Adam and
Eve fast and for free I want the
undiscreet packaging let them know let
them know
I know we're open for business this is
from Simeon USA
uh go to adamandeve.com select any one
item and use code garbage there's an
exclusive offer so be sure to support
the show and use code garbage to get 50
off free shipping Rush processing good
adamandeve.com right now send some pics
I'm doing the Patriots
I'm kidding back to the show me for me
they should start making those salsa
tins wider too by the way just a heads
up to you saw some people out there I've
never agreed with anything you said more
it's crazy make a [__] make hey what
are we doing it's ready pretty wide
though no not for those restaurant style
chips chips problem that ain't toast
that ain't [__] that ain't the good
folks that uh well first of all Tostitos
has their own line of uh uh dips the con
queso the artichoke dip or the spinach
dip
dude come on man but you get it all over
your hands and [__] they need to take a
cue from the people the big hummus those
guys are putting out perfect those guys
are putting out perfect you can get two
hands you do it you end a friend yeah
[__] full board Sabra that's like a
hot tub every we got four or five people
in there
yeah man that's the way dude you can you
can you can literally clean one of those
things where you could put it back yeah
filled with cereal everything uh okay
whoa good call day of the film monitor
which nobody ever throws nobody ever
completely rips off that'll Jam you up
too when that thing latches back and
hits your hands like a venus fly trap
hate that [__] hummus on your
knuckles yeah all right but here here
there's got to be a reason why that and
it's Gotta Be
the shelf life of hummus is way shorter
that's not a super airtight that's like
that is flimsy plastic you I think you
need four con queso or salsa you need to
be hanging around for a while you need a
jar all right so make a glass jar that's
oval
that doesn't you can't spin an oval
oh yeah
and also there's no he'd be able to grip
nobody would have the hamstring to open
up a Sabra saw his [__] jar what
about Nutella they make it work
that's plastic yeah also you can't get
to the bottom of the telephone you
really can't you know what you really
can't also you're not gonna be able to
fit a chip in [__] Nutella like a
restaurant style sure that's similar
size sure I've definitely done that
though I've definitely used tortilla
chips in Nutella I don't know what that
you salty and sweet yeah there's not
really anything you can't [__] dunk
in Nutella realist I mean you can't like
put like Korean barbecue so are people
out there maybe we're obviously we're on
the you know we we land more animalistic
when it comes to uh things sure trashy
are people filling up like little cups
of cheese and salsa then like you know
bowls then to dip the only time I think
I don't think my mom's dipping in the
salsa jar no my mom's definitely putting
in a little that's what I'm saying
really yeah I think my mind the only
time we do that if there's a if there's
a dollop of cream cheese in the middle
of that that's one that's when we'll do
it I think your mom's dunking in the jar
she doesn't [__] salsa what I mean let's
keep it north of the Border yeah
okay all right playing rebels in the
Pledge of Allegiance yeah
yeah what what are her chips
what is what is Patty snacking on
besides a couple of more beezies
there's like carrots and celery in there
there's those little pepperonis okay she
does the hormels yes your mom's your
mom's cracking out hormones oh boy it
can't be easy she eats them with
Chopstick though
stay International
um she does that she knows she's a huge
fan of let me guess chocolate Twizzlers
what loves them that's trashy Daddy I
love you they are all right the Hershey
how many she's eating those every day
dude she comes back with a bag of those
things that's what heroin addicts do
they need the sugar to keep them up
[Laughter]
she [__] with those heavy and they're
they look like Bears got into it they're
that's ripped open
uh she does Ritz
she always has that crack those Cracker
Barrel cheeses too that she slices up
shout out to him yeah those are all
right but she doesn't really wrap them
up too well there's always that not
neither does Denise man that wouldn't I
remember when I was a kid I get fast and
loose with the with the [__] food
preserve well when I was a kid and I
would see the hard pieces on on cheese
I would move it still kind of gets me
couldn't do it I bought a thing of those
pre-sliced the ones you had the other
day the priest the boars had pre-sliced
because you can't get good slice you
can't get good sliced meat really in New
York City or cheese in New York City
dealt like well I don't have a deli
if there's no Deli counter that's a
that's a convenience store you might as
well be selling tires or something they
have it pre-sliced yeah like did they do
that day or whatever I guess
like it's not like no I got it yeah I
don't [__] with it
um
but I was using that Boar's Head stuff
and man that doesn't reseal that well so
that's just eating that's just [__]
eating whatever's in the fridge just get
into that and man I tried
I tried making a bacon egg and cheese
you open up the pickles are at it with a
hard piece dude this thing wasn't
melting that's how [__] hard it got
I had the lid on this diet everything
and nothing was cracking yeah no I can't
I can't hang with that nah that's rough
um all right let's see here this one's
from Anthony's burner account never had
one red ten dollar shareholder is it
garbage to have ringtones for different
people my dad has a different ringtone
for every one of his four kids it's
crazy I don't that's an old that's an
old person thing sure that's a that's a
our parents generation thing and it's
the funeral March for the wife when they
call yeah yeah yeah some some so they
got some sort of bit going yeah the
Empire song
yeah uh any I mean whose phone isn't on
silent all the time
yeah parents always parents are always
always loud is that me yeah never know
who it is you're the only one in the
house with the volume on it it's you I
caught Patty there today she keeps
telling me that she instead of going to
church she watches Church
yeah because it has it has like a live
feed on Facebook [__] in her back pocket
walking around what are you doing
I hit the confession after that
get over there well you're just not do
it uh-huh does your mom have a tablet
it's never dude it's never an iPad it's
always if they give it to you free at
Verizon call it the Kindle that's a give
me my Kindle
this is [__] Japanese spyware you got
here this thing's bugs it's a Kia yeah
get me my Kindle I was over here looking
at the Kindle she one time asked me
she's like this thing's not working
right she has the microwave that's she
had I'm not lying 25 000 windows open in
that thing I just sat there for like it
was like I was on Tinder just [__]
swiping swiping them out dude crazy yeah
they don't always get it she plays her
games on that
now she gets in the car because she's in
the back seat now that would be our
mobile game what are you garbage
presents heaterville peterville you
gotta run around town smoking cigs
Patty's the boss
oh go in front of the Sears
light up in the fire zone at no parking
there got a ticket
told you to put your flashers on
one of the challenges bumming a light
find somebody outside of church the last
level you only have one match one match
and there's three guys smoking you gotta
make it work
somebody make that game yeah that's all
right we might have to cut this this
might be our game
heater though are you garbage presents
welcome to heaterville dude come on
big dude big tobacco will be behind that
for sure yeah it's all right get a
couple of bucks for this
there's a level where you try to quit
for a week
you just end up getting fights
[Laughter]
oh yeah I don't think that flies in The
Burbs no one's leaving hey you're not
really going now if you're out front of
a bar you got your heaters on you you
got your heaters on you oh man that's
[__] great
uh why we're on heaters there was a
couple of heater questions
uh this one's from Dave ever smoke a cig
while riding a bike for sure have done
that yeah it sucks yeah it's not as good
as you think it's like smoking on a boat
there's too much wind
the Cherry goes into the sea smoking on
a boat sucks um you think it's gonna be
cool it's so not cool it's not plus you
feel like if you throw it anywhere the
whole thing's gonna blow up it sucks you
can't even feel it go in and you can't
flick it in the ocean
really yeah dude put all the tuners and
stuff down here it's gonna end up in you
anyway cigs too man
underwater Bernies catching a heater
after a great white was on I mean you
flip them out you flick them out the
window you share a neighborhood with a
shark You're Gonna Wanna smoke you got
problems they're running you're anxious
you gotta unwind a little bit with a
cool Menthol you flick them out the
window that's the same [__] thing the
ground and the ground in the ocean are
the same thing I don't think I do flick
him out the window
oh it's is this the pr thing you're
spinning for the people out there you
think they're gonna believe that you
don't flick Bernie's out the window and
I'm supposed to sit here and and lie to
the good American people and Canadians
no way big man flicks him out the window
[Laughter]
s people Henry this one's another really
good one I've never thought about and it
sucks this is from Benny B Cups ever
smoke a heater with gloves on
can't feel it I need the this sucks
there's no tactical feeling to it it
needs to be
80 degree 80 degrees below zero for me
to put a pair of gloves on when's the
last time you had gloves on it would
have been one of those winners like
three or four years ago yeah when we
were out really humping around dude
doing bar shows I hate wearing gloves
yeah hate it uh-huh the worst
I remember shoveling my driveway you got
it and then your hands wet from the snow
you can't touch you see you can't touch
the heater you just got it in the mouth
and you're power puffing it because
they're trying to work a lighter with
that thing oh man tough half noogies
uh
um all right this one's from Dr shrimp
stick 4 000. got an MD listening to the
show
at what age has become garbage and still
live with your parents
this is more of a theory rather than a
yes or no one I don't know man if it was
up to me I'd be
I'd be there right be married to your
mom
no sex stuff but yeah
I wouldn't want to do her or nothing but
yeah I'd marry her for the benefits
she got Social Security tax purposes
dude
um
I don't know man that [__] all is it's
so much different than you know what we
no there's an age or there's some speed
bumps is there Island yeah man is there
yeah I would say then the pandemic a lot
of people moved home that's different I
know we would we went down there for a
couple of months that's different we
kept the apartment in New York obviously
but we were down there
oh man I would say
the rules have changed on that a little
bit in recent years a little bit a
little bit you can go to 19 now look at
it now hold on look at it this way
all right listen uh let me run one
scenario okay one runs in there run one
scenario you graduate high school you go
to college that you're out of the house
you stay at the summer or whatever you
come back so you're messing up right
there what are you doing I would
recommend anybody go to college start a
podcast
um
even do a real thin Market
[Laughter]
no I would uh so College you get that
you go back in the Summers that's fine
whatever whatever and I would also give
you a year after college so let's say
you graduated 21 maybe so what get an
apartment to get a job get on your feet
I would say no later
than 24. think about it even if you
didn't go to college and you entered the
workforce obviously you're not [__]
killing it right away but you got a
decent job maybe getting a union or
whatever you can get out early 20s
before 25 you can be out of your house
okay I agree with you on that you're
right you should do all that stuff
should go to college
after college you should get an
apartment with a roommate depending what
kind of I mean you might have join a
trade Union you might have a banging job
I don't know you get your own place but
what I'm saying is move back
you you want you want to be out there to
see how bad it sucks then you move back
in
I had a couple runs no I went back I
went I went back how good is it I went
back after college then I got a
townhouse with my buddy I thought you're
a real smart guy that crashed and burned
moved back to my house back to my mom's
then we got that place in Philly not
Titan street right
you never went back after that yeah you
did a couple of months before I came to
New York
okay yeah yeah I'm gonna move back I
would after college
here's the thing here's the thing get my
balls busted while I'm eating eggs
dude dinner dinner
how good are those eggs Toby not good
enough dude and here's a different
situation your parents have a condo or
whatever if your parents own their house
or whatever
that's just gonna go up that's you're
thinking of the family the family line
you're gonna want that piece of real
estate for future Generations that's
different someone's got to watch move it
home because you're a dirtbag at 30 is
different than keeping the family
property in your name well that's what
you're doing you're keeping an eye on
things I keep it keeping an eye on my
investment making sure you're putting
cyanide in my mom's oatmeal making sure
there's no loose spending going on
you got him switching a name to [__]
off off brand cereal yeah I don't know
man
um I I have some buddies who still live
at home really proper never even never
even packed a bag to move out no [__]
uh-huh really yeah
damn they got their own hookup though
they got the basement or something like
that right I'm not sure what's going on
to be honest with you I mean it's no
longer you you don't go hang if your
buddy still lives at home you don't go
to his house to hang out you know what I
mean bringing chicks back Corvette
postered pretty cool yeah shh I'm not
sleeping hey you don't go hang out at
that house yeah that would be tough yeah
you know what I mean so I haven't been
Towing upstairs I haven't been there
probably since like a year or two after
college or whatever okay
um yeah you're right
um all right what's proper age
I would say 25 with one safety net if
you move out it's not for you you can
come back maybe at 27 get your feet on
the ground if you have a lot of people
don't have that luxury obviously what
what then you know they get jammed up
and they got they gotta find a spot and
that's it which is probably better for
them mentally moving forward mature wise
because they have a gun to their head
they don't have that safety sure I mean
I know I failed because I had a safety
I'm like I'll just [__] move home oh
yeah 100 I'm all [__] up I want to
live there now
I wouldn't say 25 you should be out on
your own and then obviously like you
know I think my brother I was just
talking to my brother about this he had
to [__] uh
he had to move back home for a brief
time because they sold his building that
he was living in like he was living in a
like a apartment that somebody owned and
then they sold it and they're like you
gotta go like you either buy it or you
have to go and he had to move home in
like 30 days and you dude Chad moved
back home until he found out until he
was able to find a place to buy how do I
get back into patties what can I say the
building in something the building yeah
the building's getting sold she's not
gonna fact check you no yeah she's not
she'll welcome me with open arms take
the trash out unload the dishwasher take
the dog for a walk and be all right I'd
walk in the door my mom be like I knew
it wasn't gonna work really I knew that
Kevin was an idiot
I knew it wasn't gonna work
you loser
hey as long as the Meatloaf's hot who
gives a [__] I'll take the beaten this
when this show was happening before it
took it like before so they got
headphones Toby put your headphones on I
have your Eggies my mom like was like I
think there was like meetings happening
with siblings and other people to have
like some sort of intervention to get me
back I was like dude you tried you gave
it your shot
time to come on home get back to sucks
County try to get you to the church
Father Ryan oh I wouldn't mind it you
wouldn't it's probably low overhead you
know what I mean they take care of you
sure they do cover your court cases plus
all the old broads fall all over you and
you get to booze on the job you get the
booze on the job
couple of [__] nips I've seen some
priests uh on at Sunday mass [__] go
heavy bike on the wine like they're
doing like like jugs of it yeah and then
go back for a second one to wash down
the wafer
like you're just drinking got a helmet
on beard helmet on you ever have that
stuff uh I don't think I've ever had the
wine I don't like communal cups if I'm
being honest with you I ain't sharing
even when it's gold
I ain't sharing a cup with the [__]
old weirdos in my town
not happening
no I don't even like shaking everybody's
hand during the piece be with you part
it's a whole congregation covered in
cold sores yeah [__] out of here
I've had that wine man it is uh
it is not premium I'll tell you that
it ain't Stag's Leap I can tell you that
much cooking wine oh it sucks uh I'm
trying to get you all [__] up and do
dumb [__] let's see this one's from
coach Willie uh if you bring something
to the dry cleaner how long does it take
to pick it up
dude I still got uniforms
down here at Sparkle Cleaners it's
either I get it right away I'm on top of
it and I pick like I'll even see if it's
done early if I'm like if I'm checked in
but man I'll leave I mean there's winter
coats I got sitting somewhere what do
you think the dry cleaning businesses
like these days are dudes still doing
that like you have friends I have
friends that wear that wear suits to
work sounds like two guys you don't have
friends you have friends I got friends
I just told you my buddy's living at
home he's not getting dry cleaning done
but no we we you know we we know people
that uh that have that have you know
jobs yeah that you know get up and go to
work every day and all that kind of
stuff quit breaking
my brother works
he doesn't gotta wear a suit anymore
though well I think so this is this is
my my take on it right uh
he probably I did work in Corporate
America you know I did work in New York
City Office Buildings I know for a fact
that my brother I mean he's a sharp guy
so he's got clothes that need dry
cleaning on the regular basis sure on
the weekends he he usually dresses nicer
on the weekends than I've ever dressed
in my life like if they're going here
going there sure yeah nice pair of
slacks nice pair of slacks
maybe like not a Blazer but not a like
uh I've seen him wear button-downs on
Saturday like what the [__] are you
doing yes those dudes do that I'm naked
you can't get out of my underwear
um
I think uh two things one I think
there's probably less dry cleaning
because
things are more casual yeah than they
used to be right like workplaces are
more casual for the most part but
there's still dudes in New York City
that and ladies in New York City they
got to show up in business attire sure
yeah yeah yeah yeah but I also think the
technology has changed so those shirts
uh the Fabrics have changed so the
shirts you don't have to dry clean you
can get through with washing them and
then just like iron in them or whatever
you know my Uncle Mike it doesn't have
to be so dry clean I mean my dad too
because my dad had to worry like he wore
his [__] Navy uniform every day to
work uh-huh like every day he has a roll
in there [__] topping Tails [__]
Sharpie [__] yeah damn I wonder what my
mom was was dropping on dry cleaning I
know she had some kind of deal I think
it was way cheaper but I remember like a
dollar a shirt way back in the day it
was real you'd see signs like 99 Cents
for shirts or whatever but the next day
I remember having to go to the dry
cleaners if like you know something
happened or you got to go pick up your
Uncle Mike's stuff at the dry cleaners
like once or twice they needed it
something and damn handed me like what
what what what did you own a Macy's like
just [__] 50s I remember dudes would
have the rack
they would have like a like a bar across
their thing they would hang it that's
how much it was getting dry cleaned back
in the crazy if you're wearing like
figure if you wore you'd need three
suits a week four suits a week maybe
five shirts pants the ties the whole
nine my Uncle Mike on the shirts extra
starch
dude it was like bulletproof
um that's all right
uh this one's from Cameron hey gang
never had one red is it garbage if you
use your deceased grandmother's handicap
placard until it expires
I had a straighten Patty out with that
too I don't know listen I think you get
a grace period where you can use
plausible deniability I didn't realize
whatever whatever that's a dirt bike
that's a it's it ain't a great move no
it ain't a great move I remember I had a
friend in high school who had one
because he like sold used cars or
something because he because he flogged
social studies I wore a helmet he had uh
he had to wear uh he had one because he
like sold used cars and there was one
what we would he would try to use it I'd
be like dude wait why would you get a
handicap thing for selling used cars you
got a used car and it was in there or
something like he came across it in his
used car business like I said a dealer
Place uh and he I remember we pulled up
like Wawa I'm like dude I'm a fat piece
of [__] hop out of a [__] you know an
Aldi or whatever yeah no that's not cool
that's a tough love yeah it's not cool
my mom had one because of her Ms and
that is the I mean that is the
Disneyland fast pass to Earth bro sure
yeah zip up right by the door yeah
that's like the fire lane dude [__]
yeah
pulling up a checkout how you doing
straight me out here
yeah that's I don't agree with it I will
depends on if you're an older person me
you're a young kid you gotta You Gotta
Give it up but like your mom is an older
broad now what do you she kicked the
[__] out of both of us she's got it from
my dad wanna [__] try it Patty let me
know she's got it on the plates too
that's a little different oh no I'll
give you that because we're gonna change
I mean you know go to the DMV what are
we doing here
what are you gonna wait in line before
you're gonna ruin a Friday yeah he's
getting out of the car limping got a
neck bracelet I know the kids get
embarrassed by it when she's got to pick
him up and [__] she'll [__] pull
right up
she's elbowing people out of the way
she's gonna get her Tire slashed by a
wheelchair guy yeah yeah you can't do
that you're gonna get beat up at Acme
dude you can't do that you can't do that
you gotta get rid of that gym uh all
right this one's from Paul K you know
who used to do that all the time God
Rest his soul cotton oh cotton had a
handicap dude yeah dude because of his
mom who hadn't been in the car in
probably 20 years man he used the [__]
out of that
yeah well in the city he can help you if
you're in a pinch if you're running into
Wawa or something because they have the
parking yeah yeah yeah they don't have
that in New York I don't think handicap
no well I think in Philly that's real
Cut Throat now I think about it
if you can't make it here you can't make
it anywhere yeah there is none in Philly
at least yeah Philly takes a lot of [__]
but they have handicapped parking zones
well I think it was for if you were
handicapped you could get it on your
block like when I lived in uh North
Philly the guy across from me had it
right in front of his house like I think
like you apply to be like I need one
then somebody steals it oh man he always
[__] you're going to war all the time
steal your handicap spot yes
um people are animals this one's from
Paul K have you or anyone you ever have
you or anyone you know ever worked at a
highway rest stop restaurant or state
visitor center
think about it all the time what how do
they what do they do we've talked about
it or we've we've
I don't know if you ever talked about it
on air clock it in next to a welcome to
Georgia sign it is I think how did they
get to work do they pay the toll every
day where do these people live like when
you play they got to have a pass like a
worker's pass right to go like hey look
I'm I'm on a job here I just think I'm
flashing your badge I just think to
myself why would you get on the turnpike
to work at [__] Roy Rogers
there's
other spots you know out there I don't
know man do they do they might but the
cologne got maybe they they might they
might you might get a little two three
extra dollars an hour or something like
that wet your beak at the end of the
week
plus it's probably steady work they're
open you know what I mean sure not a lot
of people want to do it probably sure it
gets it gets filed under travel expenses
okay so it's not you you still have to
pay it's only deductible is there any
purpose [__] that is there any perk to
working at that location wait what
they're paying up front yeah that's
crazy I would sneak across Park in the
neighborhood and cut across that running
across [__] eight Lanes of traffic
retention Pond I gotta clock in in three
minutes out of my way really huh see if
there's any perk to working do they pay
more you know what I mean at a rest stop
it's got to be so maybe it's a
government job
it's not a cup Roy Rogers isn't a
government job but if it's in this thing
I think the taking care of those things
are a state job that's a good job that's
good Benny's right there I'm sure be all
right
it's a government job rest rest area
attendant not a pendant yeah the
attendant is not the guy working at the
[__] Pizza Hut slash KFC yeah the
Benny's that you're right next to with
monkeys
so hey I assume they all play ball
together right it's like a mulch ever
did you ever see the economies of a mall
it's crazy really dude my buddy get the
hook eye buddy was working at a mall in
Foot Locker in the Oxford Valley Mall in
high school and I mean day trade Foot
Locker choose this oh well the food yes
typically on you know either cheap or
very on the cuff wow but then it's like
the Jersey guys are trading shoes for
like hey I want this Kobe jersey sure be
a pair of [__] whatevers the hack
guys are all all they're all in on it
they're all just [__] moving units
trading that's pretty good it's a guy
trading 19 hats for a massage chair
that's a good deal
I tell I've my buddy used to run the two
foreign Brookstone or whatever it's
called the two for 90 deal or something
you come in you pick any two pair of
shoes yeah you use robbing the place
yeah that's what he was he was doing I
never partake the theory was you would
walk in
allegedly hand him 90 bucks or 80 bucks
whatever the 70 bucks take seven pairs
of shoes and he would hand you two pairs
of shoes that's the deal though right
yeah but then he would put the 70 in his
pocket it wasn't a wasn't an authorized
Foot Locker promotion that's a crazy
movie hold on I thought it was so you're
telling me there was no deal that was
his that was his deal in the movie that
kippy's writing yes
he was his own marketing guy yeah
exactly wait Foot Locker so Footlocker
wasn't doing a two for 90. no that was
his move yeah he was doing a sale on
stealing allegedly
allegedly he would do that
[Music]
um but you weren't allowed to use
Jordans or Timbs because they had their
own inventory system they were high-end
products walking around with Asics like
a dick I'm in the monarchs
uh yeah that never happened what are you
talking about the feds are gonna come
get you for your sneakers I don't why
would they come get me I wasn't there I
had never even been to the Oxford Valley
Mall
Franklin Mills what if I pulled out a
badge right now it was all set up that's
a hand you pull out a handicap placard
been working you for 15 years uh
who for 90. that's a [__] sweet deal
all right let's see this one's Blake uh
is it garbage use a water bottle in the
cup holder of your car to simulate a
stick shift good old-fashioned fun if
you ask me it's so funny I just did I do
it all I've been doing it since high
school
did I even make dirt bike noises when I
do it because I have to have my hand on
something and I usually keep it on the
shifter sure like on the automatic
shifter but I had a uh I had a glass
bottle in there boylan's Diet Cherry
okay oh that'll blow your hair back okay
and I I just left it in there and
driving home on Sunday because I was out
in the burbs
um I was doing it the whole way just
having it there it's a good time yeah I
feel like Jason Bourne or whatever man
yeah I do a lot of dumb [__] like that
like all you don't say I'll put like
sometimes when I have my hands on the
wheel I pretend like I have guns in the
front and I'll flip the safety up and
then do that if we were to race maybe
this is why you're a bad driver if we
were playing [__] cops and robbers
the whole time Spy Hunter the whole way
if we were to race in a manual in manual
transmission cars do you think that that
would be a big enough equalizer for me
to be competitive
if you're in an automatic no no no
everyone gets a manual
I know I mean I think we would both
smoke you yeah can you guys drive sick
100 I mean can you can't drive a regular
car so we at least have the advantage of
yeah why would you think even if you
learned how the stick shift works
you still have to then drive the car
that you don't know if we made the thing
that I can't do harder
our set of skills
you have delusions of grandeur when it
comes you couldn't beat me in a spin
race
what delusion is a Grandeur yeah that's
from Star Wars okay all right never mind
I thought you were smart for a second
that's your new imaginary world I love
now back to me shooting missiles off my
car that's some Jedi the Tatooine scene
all right I got the first reference I
don't need the page number
hahaha
that's good
for these sprung Han Solo all right shut
up and they faced a pit of sarlacc I'm
looking at a bit of Salt Lake
same digestive system a thousand years
you believe that shut up I can't anymore
okay it's the pit the Boba Fett fell in
all right but then eventually got out it
slowly digests you over a thousand years
I wish I was in it right now
he got one of those there's one of those
in New York
yeah you got handicapped pork and pull
right up now what are you saying
I was just I was saying that I I didn't
know that you could drive sick I thought
neither of you could like the wind I'm I
haven't done it in years and I wasn't
good but that would be like hey Toby
let's use an editing software you don't
know how to use and see if I'm better
than you on that software because you
don't know how to use it I'd [__] you up
yeah exactly even if you mastered not on
the track [__] even if you mastered the
stick shift you then don't know how to
drive the car I got you I was just
saying would if it would be enough of a
skill Gap to the shifting yeah you have
never been in the driver's seat of a
manual transmission I would assume have
you ever driven a car yeah
which we said we were going to do
we were going to teach Toby how to drive
hey shining bit of sarlaccially
we said we were going to teach them the
second you got in there and tried to
your you would it would stall
no I think I think I could do it
I guarante I'll bet every dollar that I
have which is seven thousand dollars
damn we've been saving
oh three thousand after the rent gets
taken out but that hasn't hit yet I
don't know why
um
okay that still hasn't hit you gotta
start poking around on that they're
gonna whack you with a couple hey I did
the app I'm done I washed my hands of it
that you the second that you got in the
car and tried to put it into gear the
car would stall I know I absolutely
could put it in the game I've driven a
motorcycle and [__] dude I know how
shifting works what do you think I think
he's an idiot
are you talking to me
yeah dude you would stall out the second
you did there's no way that you would
you would move forward I mean I would
are you talking about breaking clutching
ship first
so you do know about it a little bit
Yeah Yeah but I would also argue not
this isn't a shot to you just you
haven't done this long you would
probably stall immediately too until you
got back the hang of it no you haven't
driven in how long it would be Rocky I
wouldn't stall okay all right you know
what
for the sake of growth yes I would stall
that is a possibility that you could
sell you haven't driven an Autumn you
haven't driven I agree that I I agree
that that could possibly happen thank
you all right I'm not a know-it-all like
so and so over here
yeah
whoa what is happening here growth
that's really getting to everybody
down is Up Up Is Down yeah Toby's
driving you're admitting
something I'm not sure what happened I
don't know what just happened we should
teach you how to drive though sure
not in my car but
Dom down the Kia the [__] does that mean
it's a piece of [__] that's what that
means I got a goddamn lease going here
what I have at least two yeah but it's
like
the South Korean car come on it's coming
for the guy spending all of his money
[Laughter]
I made eight bucks
increase all my spend nine
you make it you spend nine that's how
you do it uh-huh
um
all right let's see here
this is from William Ferguson is it
garbage to brush your teeth and pee at
the same time
that's a task I was never able to I it's
too much I'm missing oh I'm all over the
place I'm missing now it's that for it's
can you do it can you do the tap of the
road yeah I just gotta start the one
first
I don't think I could do the other side
though so I don't think I could
hey Sammy frosting knock it off will you
you're one step a little juggling get
out of here what are you doing is this
your card
I can't pee I can but it's a mess if
it's too much
lateral I don't know what's happening
IP everywhere I got all loopy-eyed dead
bedroom I know I share bathrooms with
you it's like a large amount you should
just stand over why don't you start
sitting no no I I told you when I tried
to start doing and you shunned me for it
you're peeing in the tub yeah now that's
that's a step in the wrong direction
sure
um work on my aim there you go
um kid's a dead eye
I can't do it yeah I can't do that
to the point where I go I just it's too
much concentration I just go I'll just
figure I'll just whatever you know I do
enjoy brushing my teeth and walking
around though this is my theory I think
there's two P there's two kind of brains
where I have to do that I have to walk
around I walk out I walk into the
bedroom and I walk out the hallway into
the living room I walk out I look out
the windows I walk oh I feel like I'm on
a TV show I don't know why I feel like
Alex P Keaton from Family Ties okay
Michael J fox okay I feel like that
would have been his move walk around
yeah I feel like my brain I don't know I
need to be distracted or something while
I'm doing it it's something weird to
fill the time because you got to do it
for like 30 seconds
that's what they say two minutes isn't
it two minutes yeah brushing your teeth
T-Bone get a two minute Ada
recommendation that's how long I shower
for 30 30 30 30. I think it's 30 a
quadrant if I remember correct what get
the [__] out of here two minutes two
times a day two minutes yeah it's 30 a
quadrants two minutes you're missing
teeth I mean I'm missing TV out of there
be out of there quick
I'm missing three T so you take off 15
seconds for that they're throwing a
piece of trident called a day you know
what I did start doing what's that and
I'm telling you right now pooping in the
fridge if you want
if you want to change your day up
tomorrow morning when you wake up gang
going to the bathroom before you brush
your teeth use the mouthwash mouthwash
then brush you it feels fantastic is
that what they say you're supposed to do
I think yeah because in the fluoride
stays on your teeth the mouthwash wash
washes the floor right away yeah did I
see that on Instagram someone said that
in here yeah we want to just recently
talked about that okay Joe cool you're
somebody was a big teeth guy I think
something like that
um it's great we do a lot of recording
it's great
uh uh yeah I don't know if I've ever
done that
really freshens it up
I did it this morning with scope
love scope Listerine kick rocks Scopes
like a drink
it's delicious
um all right let's see here this one
aygs long lost fourth member okay have
you ever bought a product we are hiring
have you ever bought a baby or not we
are not hiring
send your applications in trying to trim
some of the fat as it is what that
wasn't doing pretty good that wasn't a
you joke that was a Toby joke
never
love you buddy
um get rid of them now
Toby leave this
[Laughter]
uh uh leave the issues and get out
no it's new girl do you think new guy
Luke still listens to the show
I think he I think he pretends
he's probably not going to hear this
this will be a test [__]
new guy Luke let me know if you hear
this we're what 55 minutes into the
episode yeah something like that yeah
yeah new guy Luke if you don't report
back
getting the scissors out cutting yeah
caught him
I run a tight ship Luke the code word is
Indianapolis
no we're going that'll come up too much
the code word is Annapolis that's what I
meant to say tube of sarnack tube of
sarnack idiot what is it it's the pit of
sarnak sarlacc hey you got me [__] up
a chocolate
what are you doing
um have you all right ayg's long lost
fourth member have you ever bought a
product at a grocery store not in the
original aisle I.E cookies in the toilet
paper aisle
no I couldn't do it you don't feel too
tempered and pick something up that's
not there that someone else left that's
weird to me of well that would never
happen but I also
I've always gotten yelled at that I had
to put it back you should you should
always as a guy my mom did that my dad
did that and the bird does that she's
like someone stocks those shelves not
that I wanted I mean obviously I'm in I
go I go back and put it back I get I run
out and you leave it you leave it as a
guy who used to have to block the
shelves that's what they call it an
abyss when you pull everything all right
I was a hell of a blocker
um
I thought they have to throw it out
what like it's like meat or something
probably yeah I mean if it was me I'd
probably just take a temperature on it
and if it was still cool I'd throw it
back
shrimp will be all right
yeah I always thought anything you you
were I mean like a like if toilet paper
was in the cookie roll the cookie aisle
if somebody left for some reason I can
visually see a red bag of Chips Ahoy
cookies in your pocket in like the
toilet paper route I thought you would
have to throw that out because that
could have been tampered with more than
likely it was
you know more than likely it wasn't if
somebody was going to tamper with it I
mean if it's a closed yeah it just goes
back on the Shelf really yeah what do
you think I mean if it's closed what do
you think somebody could have done to it
I don't know stuck a needle in it or
something squirted something in it I
thought anything if they were gonna
poison it wouldn't they put it back
where it was
to get that's what they'd want you to
think
what that's what they'd want you to
think but then if they put it there oh
this might be something
that would be everybody operates under
the understanding that if it's there it
gets thrown out
right
huh
you know what I mean you would want to
you would want it to look like a regular
product so it could be purchased
that's what we want you that's what the
person would want you to think if they
were poisoning it I don't know I don't
trust it okay fair enough clearly we've
yeah I wouldn't go near it okay never
yeah no it just if it was in someone
else's car and I know that it's theirs I
want a fresh one
yeah it's never been you always take the
you don't take the top of the thing no
it's always two back milk especially
never you know what I'm big on coffee
Lids I go to the middle oh yeah
straws too I don't [__] with straws but
sure
I like turtles just as much as the next
guy I throw out four straws before I get
to the one that I'm using I don't go
near the first straw or the first napkin
or the first pump of anything like the
ketchup things I'll throw one of those
out oh yeah yeah I want something from
the middle yeah that's something
non-touched don't like it would you guys
ever buy anything off the clearance
shelf that's in the grocery store that's
usually by like where you go into the
back and towards the stock room where
the [__] are you shopping there's no
clearance Shelf at the grocery store do
you remember isn't there it's in very
like a clothing store [__] yeah that's
the best find a sweater for six dollars
there's a clearance shelf in every
grocery store it's not always towards
the back there is a lot of time really
yeah yeah yeah I remember the beginning
of this it's always Jarred gravy for
some reason
yeah shout out to it good Heinz Jarred
gravy do you remember my dad used to
Jazz that up real nice remember when
this version went about a pepper first
started ayg it was the pandemic I was
down there we were Skyping we were doing
hard feelings every day for the public
it's the 94 pack of chicken legs that
you got that was in the clear
I was getting buy one get three there's
easier ways to kill yourself dude
buy one get three free packs of chicken
dude they were moving units [__]
Wuhan sale over here get out of here
dude I remember my mom came down she was
like why is where's all this chicken
from I'm like well
I couldn't leave it it was freebies bad
economic decisions man that's when I
pounce
yeah
he bought that in a bunch of real estate
Acme overshot the demand that's their
fault this is where I strike
no if that's clearance it was in the
meat clearance section I'm telling you
there's no meat that's manager special
that's different it said clear that's
VIP as far as I was concerned I was
ordering the specials Patty used to
always go manager special we would
always get that's got about two that's
got to get on a grill in two hours
manager special does
go right in the freezer man nah why
would Acme shout out to the why would
Acme down there in like 20
25th Street or whatever in Delaware they
have a clearance section for the meat
I'm telling you check it out tell them
Patty I didn't know it was a clearance
section Patty was definitely in that
manager special
a lot yeah
questionable chicken fingers
all right we gotta wrap it up my dad
wouldn't touch it gang we love you to
death we're on the road tickets are
moving pretty goddamn quick I ain't
gonna lie to you sure do yourself a
favor come out and see us it's a good
time we love you to death and we will
see you uh next week we are in Magooby's
very limited tickets left there
Magooby's in Timonium slash Baltimore
Delaware then we got Virginia Beach and
Richmond Virginia all next week 14 15 16
of March get those Dickies baby plenty
of tickets there
a manager special Everything Must Go
we overshot the demand of the funny
bones see you next week peace